[MUSIC]
My name is Eduardo Lins Henrique, I'm
the co-founder of a company called Movile.
Now I am the CEO of Wavy.
My career before SEP was mostly
about being an entrepreneur,
full of dreams, always thinking big,
but I was missing framework and
knowledge and techniques to deal
with the growth of my company.
[MUSIC]
What we learn at SEP is,
how can i be much better?
How can i disrupt my current business to
create something 10, 20, 50 times bigger?
SEP brought to me not only the framework,
the books, the theories,
but also the networking with colleagues,
also a networking of professors and
specialists in certain areas
that helps me a lot when I
have a challenge or I need to build
a new plan in your area, a new company.
Sometimes being a CEO or
being an entrepreneur,
it's a very lonely experience.
Having access to a group friends
that are in the same level
that you are and
sometimes feel the same way that you feel,
you can give a call,
you can ask for advice.
[MUSIC]
If you're thinking about coming to SEP,
it's important for
you to be ready to change, to change and
have a higher impact in your life,
higher impact in your company,
higher impact in the world,
because this is absolutely
transformational.
[MUSIC]